you have to give women a safe place to
raise the issues because the really big
stuff the sexual harassment that stuff
so happens I'm not saying it always gets
reported it doesn't but there are
systems in place to deal with it if you
are really sexually harassed at least
there's an HR person you can go to and
do a complaint but really and that's
hugely important and I know we need to
do better but what happens when like
you're getting interrupted in meetings
you're gonna go complain about your boss
who's probably a perfectly great guy who
thinks he's fabulous on women that's
what's happening right it's these paper
cuts but these paper cuts are the
culture are creating the problem and you
can't go like file an HR complaint I got
interrupted right
even though let's be clear those are the
biases holding us back so one of the
things that's happened we launched lean
in circles with my situation when we
launched lean in 3 years ago and there
are 31,000 lean in circles all over the
world half are in companies there are 70
a chase for example they give you a safe
place to anonymously give that feedback
so rather than your perfectly nice boss
who thinks he's fabulous on gender being
told he's interrupting women more than
men are being told he's giving men
credit for women's ideas which he
probably doesn't know he's doing we
provide training but more importantly
these circles give you a nice anonymous
place and then the circle leaders can
meet with the head of HR or in great
companies with the CEO and say this is
happening and then you can do the bias
training with the data from your own
company so it is huge to acknowledge we
have the problem and I think the third
thing is and UN Women has led here is we
have to give men a reason to participate
and again I think it has to go back to
what's good for them it is the right
thing to do no doubt but we've known
that for a long time and it hasn't
happened so if you are a man why should
you be a more active husband and father
why do laundry other than the fact that
I tell men all over the world you're
gonna have more sex if you do laundry
that's a really good reason but why do
it why do it because you're gonna have a
happier marriage because the divorce
rate goes down because depression for
your wife goes down why do more child
care and try to get the balance a little
more
it's not even anywhere in the world
because your kids and this is regardless
at any income level are gonna do better
in school be more the healthier happier
and and better adjusted that's a really
good reason to do more housework and
childcare if you're a man in the
workplace why because if you can use the
full talents of the population rather
than half
you're gonna outperform your peers and
that's true whether you're the entry
level employee where no one reports to
you but you're just better to work with
or you're the chief marketing officer of
Unilever or the CEO you're gonna do
better and so I think if we can convince
you know companies to market to women
against stereotypes because it'll sell
their products if we can convince men to
do their share at home and to fight
gender bias in the workplace because
they'll be happier more successful in
both fronts that's where the win is and
the good news is as all of these amazing
panelists have said the data is on our
side